The brigade, the rosier
[inaudible] stupid nuts.
[inaudible] dear friends.
They've finally chosen the name for element 115.
And the name is Moscow Liam, or perhaps with a Russian accent.
Must scorpion.
The reason they have chosen a Russian name is because the element was
sensitized for the first time in [inaudible] somewhere to the North
of Moscow is the big research center where
elements synthesis has been studied for the last 30 or more
years.
Originally under the leadership of flurry of after whom
flerovium was named quite recently as were the other elements.
The way that you make these elements is by accelerating
very light iron it's very high speed into
a heavy element and the nuclei fuse together. Now,
the problem is that both nuclear are positively charged.
So you need a lot of energy to overcome the repulsion positive against
positive, but then once it's made,
you didn't want too much energy, or it will immediately fall to bits.
It's a bit like trying to jump from the ground onto the top of a
flagpole. You might get there,
but then overbalance straight away and fall off again to do this.
It's not just enough to choose the right atomic numbers,
but you'll have to choose the right isotope.
That's the atoms with the correct number of protons and
neutrons. So that in combination you get to stable number,
it's really important to understand that calcium 48 is a
very rare isotope of calcium,
less than 0.1% of naturally occurring calcium.
And it's very expensive to produce.
And there is only one plant in the whole of Russia,
one plant in the whole world that can make calcium 48.
They ionize the calcium atoms and then separate the magnetically
as in a mass spectrometer.
So you need huge amounts of electricity to produce a few
milligrams of the compound. And apparently in one experiment in Duke,
now they use the million dollars worth of calcium 48.
In these experiments, you're bombarding.
The tongue gets Emory SIM with trillions of calcium irons,
and only very rarely does the correct fusion take place.
And you make one of the nuclei of element 115.
Very fortunately, when you are successful,
the element comes out to the back, almost in the straight line,
whereas when it blows up fragments in something else,
the fragments go in all directions.
So if you put a very narrow slit behind your target,
you can get not just element 115,
but the subset of fragments that contains that,
and most of the junk goes away.
Muskogee Liam is in group 15.
That's the group that begins with nitrogen and then phosphorous.
And what is interesting about this group is that it includes arsenic,
which is very poisonous,
used to be used by poisoners to kill their wives or husbands.
But now as you go down the CR you come to bismuth the element immediately
above Muskogee and bismuth is surprisingly and poisonous it's even
used in medicines. So it's a very interesting question.
If you had a large quantity of Muskogee, Liam,
would it be poisonous or not?
It's also interesting to think whether the chemistry
would be similar to that,
to phosphorus arsenic and bismuth or whether like bismuth,
it would be almost like a metal you can get, for example,
phosphorous Penta, fluoride, PFI, five arsenic, Penta, fluoride,
but you don't get these Penta fluorides of business,
or at least you don't get them so easily.
So there'd be a lot of interesting chemistry, but unfortunately,
the technology so far will not allow you to do that sort of chemistry.
Moscow is one of my favorite cities.
And so obviously I'm delighted.
Muscovy is one of the few elements named after capital city.
And most of the others are not easily recognizable because for example,
lutetium is named after Paris, but it's a Latin name that unless, you know,
doesn't seem to relate to Paris at all. So I think it's a very good name,
as I mentioned before,
Scottish viewers will like it because it has a symbol MC and many
Scottish surnames begin with MC.
So they're going to be a lot of people in Scotland who can now spell their name
with the elements of the periodic table.
Making Muskogee him has been a fantastic piece of international collaboration
because although the experiments were done in Russia,
they re lied on having samples of Amaris Siham,
which were made in America.
These are very specialist experiments where you need a
particular facility that can make the act you want.
We're talking about the starting material of milligrams
or less. So even if the process was very efficient,
you would only get milligrams of the element.
And because of the low probability, forming them
about really quite small numbers of atoms being formed.
And in this paper, which is about the sensitive,
the heavy elements they're giving the numbers of the atoms of these different
elements, 118 hundred and 17, so on. So for 115,
the highest number that any lab has seen that's in Dubliner is
27 atoms of a particular isotope.
Just to make that clear in my teacup,
there are probably 10 to the 26 or 10 to the
27 atoms.
It is really almost incalculable that you can start costing up this
element atom by atom and each atom.
Probably if you take in all the costs will cost millions of dollars.
Whereas with gold, for millions of dollars, you can get several kilos,
but for here,
you got one atom and it doesn't last very long.
So it's the ultimate gift to give to somebody.
You might just have enough time to say, I love you before the atom decays.
It's the million dollar items. Yes.
We already have an element named after Doug ner Doug medium. Is it overkill?
You know, now having Moscow them, are they, are they hugging all the names?
I think it's fair enough.
You have to bear in mind that there are some places that have at least four
elements named after them,
particularly it had been the small islands near Stockholm
and there's California.
Berkelium Le ransom and live a Moriam are all in
California. So I don't think it's unreasonable
in my pockets.
I've got this and this is a real Nobel prize
metal. It's a real Nobel prize metal made of gold.
It's the metal that was won by my colleague at the Royal society to pull nurse
the precedent. And I borrowed it for this lecture.